welcome back to CBS mornings here at 7
30 and as Republicans take control of
the house Hunter Biden the president's
son will be a target for investigations
and that means data from a laptop
reported to belong to Biden could be
crucial to the investigatory process CBS
News has obtained its data not through a
third party or political operative but
directly from the source who told us
they provided it to the FBI under
subpoena and we commissioned an
independent forensic review to determine
its authenticity senior investigative
correspondent Catherine Harris joins us
now with what we found Catherine I'm
very interested good morning Good
morning Tony these house Republican
investigations are coming and that could
be a challenge for the White House as we
head into 2023 and 2024. the laptop data
we had analyzed showed no evidence it
was faked or tampered with
well digital forensic investigator Mark
lanterman was previously a member of a
secret service electronic crimes task
force there was one thing that got my
attention and that was a voicemail
in the whole world pal
to get some help that voicemail
apparently from Joe Biden during his son
Hunter's drug addiction is one of many
findings lanterman used to authenticate
what is believed to be Hunter Biden's
laptop data you're confident based on
your analysis this is Hunter Biden's
data and that it's real yes this
Delaware computer shop is where the
laptop's backstory begins their records
indicate in April 2019 Hunter Biden took
his laptop in for repair but never paid
after 90 days the store considered it
abandoned then in December 2019 the FBI
subpoenaed the store's owner to turn
over the computer and a portable drive
of its data whatever happened to Hunter
during the 2020 election versions were
widely shared by Republican operatives
including Rudy Giuliani we have the
entire hard drive but questions were
raised about whether additional files
were added to those versions then
candidate Biden labeled the laptop
controversy disinformation what this
he's accusing me of is a Russian plant
CBS News approached the lawyer for the
computer repair shop owner to cut
through the noise we've always had uh
one clean copy and obtained a copy of
what he says they provided the FBI under
subpoena then we went to Minneapolis for
an independent analysis were you paid by
CBS or anyone else to analyze the data
no no
I wouldn't want anyone to think that
someone bought our opinion around the
corner it'll lead you to what we call
our Imaging room landerman and his son
Sean both digital forensic experts
recovered images of credit cards a
driver's license social security number
just the sheer volume of what we're
dealing with it would be difficult if
not impossible to fabricate and
explained how files built up over years
it accumulated over time which is
consistent with normal everyday use of a
computer there's some reporting about
folders being added we have read these
articles we don't see that so I believe
that that's because we have a more
pristine copy the laptop and its
contents have fueled Republican interest
in Hunter Biden's business ventures
Hunter Biden was working with Chinese
Nationals they say this may 2017 email
outlining a proposed business deal with
a Chinese energy firm is one reason why
they have questions about whether
President Biden benefited we're prepared
to subpoena Hunter Biden we would
certainly hope that he would want to
come before the committee and clear his
name two of Hunter Biden's former
business partners including Tony
bobolinski who received the email told
CBS News the 10 held by H for the big
guy is shorthand for 10 percent held by
Hunter for his father after the email
became public in 2020 the author of the
email told the Wall Street Journal Joe
Biden was not involved the author has
not responded to CBS news's questions Mr
Biden has consistently denied knowledge
of his son's work or financially
benefiting from it I've never spoken to
my son about
last month Senator Chuck Grassley wrote
this letter alleging bank records and
financial data showed that Hunter Biden
and the Pres resident's brother profited
from a five million dollar wire from a
company connected to cefc the Chinese
energy firm they're going to look at
every part of the Joe Biden
Administration Doug high is a Republican
strategist a lot of this is also going
to be aggressive on Hunter specifically
we're going to hear a lot about the
laptop who profited was the law broken
was it not broken after two years of
scrutiny the laptop has not produced
evidence President Biden directly
benefited from his son's business deals
if there's dirt there that will dirty
them up if not those attacks can
backfire
the White House declined to comment
Hunter's lawyer did not address our
specific questions about the data or the
CBS forensic review but said there have
been multiple attempts to hack in fact
distort and pedal misinformation
regarding Mr Biden's devices and data
and at no time did any individual
including the it repair shop owner Mr
mcisaac have Mr Biden's consent to
access his computer data or share it
with others the lawyer also referred us
to Hunter Biden's Memoir where the
president slammed the Despicable
opposition that purported to have a
laptop belonging to him Gail
it could be a lesson to pay your bills
85 dollars could have changed everything
had the bill been paid thank you very
much Catherine always good to have you
here good to see you